Every image you've seen of a black hole,
including this one, is a fantasy.
A genuine picture of a black hole doesn't exist,
but soon, that's going to change.
Black holes in their own don't look like very much.
They don't reflect light
because any light that falls into them can never escape.
And they don't emit any light that we can detect
Those aren't the only reasons black holes
are hard to photograph.
Even though they're really, really massive —
they can be millions or billions of times
the mass of the Sun
— they don't take up that much space on the sky.
They've compressed all that mass
into a really tiny, little space.
The closest big black hole to Earth
is at the centre of the Milky Way,
which is 26,000 light-years away from us.
And so in order to be able to see something of that size,
we need a telescope that has a resolution that is
powerful enough that it could see
a doughnut on the surface of the moon.
The black hole illustrations we're all familiar with
aren't complete lies.
Plenty of data suggest that black holes exist.
Some even shoot jets into space that we can see
and spaghettify stars that get too close.
The best evidence for these behemoths
is their entourage.
They wrap huge amounts of gas
and like charged plasma around them.
And as that stuff is trying to fall into the black hole,
it can't all go in at once,
so it orbits super, super, super fast.
And the friction in that fast orbiting heats it white-hot.
Most illustrations focus on the accretion disk,
but soon, we could be looking at the real deal —
thanks to the Event Horizon Telescope or the EHT.
The EHT is trying to take the first picture
of the black hole at the center of the Milky Way.
It's called Sagittarius A* or Sgr A* for short.
And the team expects to produce results later this year.
What it's actually doing is taking a picture of
the shadow of the black hole on the stuff behind it.
By stuff, she means the glowing gas and plasma
in the accretion disk.
The black hole's shadow should create
a silhouette on the disk that outlines
the point of no-return — the event horizon.
Taking such a picture would require
a really, really big telescope.
The EHT uses a lot of smaller radio telescopes instead.
They work together using a technique called
very long baseline interferometry
and what that does is it makes those
telescopes kind of act like one giant telescope.
Scientists analyzing the data can see
how the light waves detected by each telescope
line up with each other to figure out
what's light from the edge of the black hole
and what's noise.
The EHT's picture will most likely look like a ring,
created by the black hole's event horizon
blocking out light from behind.
That first image, though perhaps grainy,
will give us an up-close look at the accretion disk
plus two key bits of information:
the size and shape of the black hole's shadow.
And then that will be enough to answer
a lot of interesting astrophysical questions
about how black holes work,
how event horizons work
and what is going on there.
There the big unanswered questions include:
How exactly do accretion discs
form and feed black holes?
Where do black hole jets originate?
And the oldie but always a goodie,
was Einstein right?
His general theory of relativity predicted that
event horizons could conceal tiny, massive objects
like black holes.
The shape of this image that we see is something
that you can predict using general relativity.
If the shape of the image of the black hole
looks different than we expect,
that would mean that something's wrong
that we don't fully understand about general relativity.
Taking a picture of a black hole will mark
the most extreme test of general relativity yet.
This test of relativity also has implications for
the physics theory of it deals with very small objects,
quantum mechanics.
The two of them don't play well together.
We don't understand how gravity works
on sort of quantum levels.
And if we see something that differs from our
expectation in this picture of the black hole,
that can help point us to one of many theories
that try to reconcile quantum mechanics
and general relativity.
It's also just cool.
Whether it's a pale blue dot
or a pristine portrait of Pluto,
seeing has always offered us
a new perspective on the universe.
Humans are very visual,
and so we love having images.
And I think having an actual picture of black hole
is just going to blow people's minds.
Am I going to like break continuity
if I roll up my sleeves?
And I'm going to start this one over.
This is hard.
I was just watching the
Great British Baking Show last night.
Ummm.
They wear the same clothes
two days in a row.
We'll go there, yeah.
I feel like it's wrong.
Sorry, yeah, you can cut that.
So, don't roll up your sleeves then.
Something like that. [Laughs]
[Laughing]